[Music]
i try to give myself some grace with my
just in case items i have some very
expensive saxophones that i'm holding on
to just in case however should i need
them back in my life it would cost
thousands to get them back so those
items get to stick around so let's talk
about
expensive yeah just in case items
yeah i mean
that's a really good excuse sarah
[Laughter]
it's a really good excuse and any excuse
is still a just an excuse that's right
um
it
this isn't a judgment sarah i'm just
thinking of myself i actually have a
saxophone that i'll play every once in a
while especially like i don't know why
but it's really easy to play some of the
christmas songs yeah so i usually break
it out for christmas and i'm just like
playing with mariah i had a friend who
taught saxophone and would come over and
like we'd have lessons together but she
moved so now it's just me annoying
mariah with my saxophone but i enjoy
playing it every once in a while same
thing with my guitar um same thing with
my cajon although that also doubles as
like an end table yeah so there are some
musical instruments i have that i
actually use however
if i had several saxophones i would be
looking
at those with kind of a little bit of uh
twinge of resentment or like just some
negative type of feeling of like
man like this is taking up space i'm not
using all these saxophones
um and actually sarah i would posit
that you could get them back if you sell
them for thousands of dollars
you could buy them back for thousands of
dollars and i guarantee see what she
knows is that when she has the thousands
of dollars in her hands she's not going
to be willing to give up those thousands
of dollars to bring them back which
in itself should be a symptom but
i would i would encourage you to set up
some boundaries that work for you sarah
maybe this is a boundary if it costs
over a thousand dollars i keep it great
that's your boundary sarah keep your
saxophone
the question is is that boundary serving
you or is it holding you back
sarah why are you holding on to these
saxophones if it's because they add
value to your life
wonderful i don't want you to get rid of
them right we are minimalists we are not
deprivationists
and so holding on to them if it adds
greater value if it adds benefit to your
life
wonderful or maybe
it just so happens that one or two of
them add value to your life and the rest
of them are getting in the way so what
do you do you determine if i sold all of
these right now say you have 10
saxophones and they're worth a thousand
bucks each and you can get a thousand
dollars for them used
wonderful
would you take that same 10 000 and
replace all of them right now or would
you replace one or two of them
and if the answer is yeah of course i
would definitely buy one saxophone i
want to have a saxophone yeah great well
you just made nine thousand dollars then
by getting rid of the things that are in
the way and paradoxically you're going
to enjoy the other saxophone so much
more because you're not burdened with
all of the excess saxophones that are
just getting in the way and by the way
this applies to any other just in case
items that are expensive or any just in
case item in general
would you replace that item it's our
spontaneous combustion rule yeah if you
wouldn't replace it
well that's a surefire sign that i am
going to let go i'm going to sell it i'm
going to donate it i'm going to find
someone else who actually will who
actually will get value out of it um
what about all my dogecoin
[Laughter]
is that worth anything these days i have
no i have no dogecoin man i don't know
why i thought about that i was just you
talked about having ten thousand dollars
and you're like would you replace the
saxophones or do you invest in
dogecoin i found a nickel with bite
marks on it in the street oh yeah yeah
yeah it was a bitcoin oh
good one thank you good one good one um
did you notice like someone is reaching
out to us on all platforms asking us
about cryptocurrency
yeah i i'm so curious well let's bring
tk on because he understands crypto
oh yeah i don't get it i need i yeah i
need to understand it a little bit
better myself but it's funny because
people are asking like what's your
opinion on i'm like i have no opinion
yeah it's like asking my opinion on
rocket science yeah well
it gets rockets to the moon i think i
mean my my answer to both of those is
the same my opinion doesn't matter in
fact i keep answering whenever someone
asks me about bitcoin
when they say what is your opinion
my opinion doesn't matter what what is
the truth behind bitcoin i don't
understand enough about bitcoin to be
able to talk about it intelligently
but tk coleman is a savant in this area
so we we can you know we
yeah i would love to talk to him about
it yeah we'll bring him on to talk about
it did you enjoy this video if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free